Salam alaikum wa rahmatullah better care
to brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are doing well
I think this video I'm doing here is
maybe the court may be with 275 videos
on YouTube and many thousands more on
social media I think this is the only
ever time that something has impacted me
so much that right now there and then if
you can just get the camera just look
around where we are we're actually in
Montana office which is a charity and
basically yet impact on me so much that
I said you know what like malaya
the least I can do is just place video
so the video you're gonna watch now
Allah he just watch it for yourself
there's nothing I can say there's
nothing like and the brothers were here
well I all of us we were holding back
our tears because it's so profound it's
soft like life-changing that Allah says
in the Quran if you save a single
service it says if you save the whole of
humanity and if you kill one services we
cure the whole of humanity over here
we're talking about saving one so when
you watch the video just watch for
yourself
it would be safe self-explanatory we
just want you guys inshallah to come
onboard and we're trying to get set my
target person he is seven people so ten
thousand five hundred pounds by tonight
well I he anyone that watches that video
we our minimum target should be saving
seven people and not only are you saving
these little kids some of them are
babies their lives you saving their
lives be the go hatch fasting praying
this Allah whatever they do from this
moment onwards that their heart you know
the procedures goes right you you the
when you watch the video when their
mother and father's crying not knowing
if their son or daughter's gonna make it
you have played a part in changing their
life and whatever be bother that child
us it's on your skills and Baba this is
what like I just don't want to keep it
long very short inshallah I would talk
is ten five hundred miles you can see
that link here and also saving little
hearts DoCoMo
the little hearts don't comment sorry do
check that is well inshallah we're
trying to get about 50 more people to
donate
raise do some fundraising be in your
community or found members five thousand
inshallah you can check the link at the
end please watch this video that's all
I'm gonna say inshallah biographies none
of this you guys
[Music]
this a seven-year-old boy he's suffering
from a very large hole in his heart that
is a week of all actual septal defect it
is a second imperfect it is a almost
three centimeter or by 15 1 point 5
centimeter is very huge and it has
caused his right chamber very much
dilated and his pulmonary artery is
dilated but luckily his permit patient
is still normal so we can proceed
[Music]
the punishment that a person that I'm
learning about the cherish Altamonte but
the question of our value for our show
who our children have but it's also I
would like at the by telling I go to the
very last show one other missions over
it now imaginable artichoke liqueur be
morality we are completely natural
immune normal for our journey for you my
only wonder I ate until d-tector big tea
Loulou
[Music]
LibDems everybody would inflate again
Nikki what the list whatever
nobody
again
how come I feel afraid I'll empty near
couldn't be the same
[Music]
okay this is rocky again yeah you can
see once again his operation is done it
was a very difficult operation and
life-saving operation as well now is
every parameter sarahstravels heart rate
blood pressure and saturation we are
really happy because the baby is
recovering very good up from the Allah
the rest is Hoover like a meat locker
room fantasy I don't understand so while
again some lettuce unlucky so when the
guys wanna go to Goa I'm already at or
before
Takeda America sites which are nearly
immediate cyanide potential abalone very
cute idea means they would marry Basha
I'm eternally I mean money would be a
whole number to do got me I'm Erika
Silverman
I have no moral she did their eyes would
go me don't know what am i right I'll
get on YouTube at harmonic I'll get up
to Turkey so welcome to bottom you see
the cure to a military armory tehrani
iconic chastity
I'm tested understands it there are more
every trivia but reverse I see haven't
even so at least the Lego to Allah but
Allah and I am develop Buddha Allah to
develop swivelling develop Antonia
Bazarov see swab Allah give you optimal
Maria yamaraja concentration of nada the
manometer la cámara de de
[Music]